instagram is one of the best platforms
to grow your influence and your income
right now and in this episode of coffee
with kennel i'm going to be talking to
bra brock johnson who's an instagram
expert and we're going to be learning a
lot of stuff so buckle your seat
seatbelt because if you want to build a
community of loyal followers if you want
the working proven tactics and
strategies that are getting huge results
on instagram right now
if you actually want to get real results
and not just more followers that are
inactive and if you're curious about how
to make money on instagram all of that
and more is coming up on this episode of
coffee with kennel so let's get into it
three two one
[Music]
welcome back to coffee with kennel sean
cannell here let me know what you're
drinking in the chat i'm sipping on some
vesta coffee from las vegas ethiopian
blend single origin it's delicious
uh but shout me out what you're sipping
on today hey if you haven't met brock
johnson he's a 24 year old entrepreneur
with a passion for helping others grow
their following and their business on
instagram as a co-host of a top 50
business pond podcast an instructor of
multiple online courses he's a viral
tick-tock creator a former college
athlete and brocht has helped
brock has helped thousands of
entrepreneurs learn to build their
businesses on social media even with
limited time and money so if you are
ready to learn about some of the newest
features the newest updates and the
newest ways to make a major impact on
instagram that's what we're talking
about today plus we have a cool
announcement about a free
three-day
instagram bootcamp that brock is doing
info in the description down below but
we'll talk that about that a little bit
later but let's welcome brock johnson to
coffee with kennel today brock how's it
going sean i'm awesome how are you doing
dude i'm fired up i mean a little bit
jaded because you had me schedule this
at 7 30
a.m pacific standard time and uh but hey
we're here and i mean we're caffeinated
i'm ready to go here i'm caffeinated i'm
ready to go i think the only my only
disappointment is that we're not doing
this in person we're 45 minutes apart
right now why are we not sitting across
the table from each other i know for
real we just realized that i'm actually
at the seattle think media studios
really north north north not even in
seattle but i just say seattle because
nobody would actually know where i am
brock is coming to you from seattle
washington but brock i'm so fired up
let's just get right into this you got
five tips for us today uh what's tip
number one yeah five tips the five big
changes on instagram in 2021 um the
first one is probably gonna be pretty
evident to everyone and that's the that
reels are the best right now there's
nothing better than reels on instagram
in in terms of your different types of
content um they're the best in just
about every category they're getting
more engagement than just about anything
else our studies have shown that they're
averaging almost two times the reach as
your non-reels so if you're posting a
picture or a normal video or a carousel
slideshow to your instagram and
comparing that to your reels typically
your reels are getting about double the
amount of reach uh that those non-reels
are and also another really interesting
thing is we talk about shelf life or
longevity of content on social media
and typically when we think of instagram
we think of that as a a big problem that
content on instagram has because youtube
content can last on for years and years
and years i'm searching things on
youtube all the time and finding a think
media video from five years ago and it's
helping me out today that's happening a
lot less on instagram but with reels
we're noticing something different we're
noticing a trend starting to emerge with
reels
and that's that they're getting
discovered and seen and they're getting
shown to large amounts of people
days or weeks or months or we've now
even seen because they've been around
for a year
years after they were originally posted
so you can post a reel today and it
might not do so great it might get
relatively average engagement or even
below average engagement for what you
typically expect and then suddenly three
months from now for whatever reason it
starts picking up views and starts
getting seen by thousands of people
well brock you know
that kind of gets me excited almost like
youtube gets me excited most of the
people in the think media kind of
podcast and think media podcast channel
community um love youtube because it's
the only platform where your content
lives forever but to have a longer shelf
life even to the tune of months and
years
is super super exciting and let me ask
you some questions about reels we're
looking at my instagram homepage if i
click to the reels tab we're seeing um
for those in fact let me know in the
chat or in the comments have you posted
a reel yet
uh have you experimented with reels um
and my question for you is how long uh
can you post reels up to and what does
it take to unlock the longer length
yeah so as of right now you can record
up to 60 second reels and according to
instagram everyone should have access to
up to 60 second reels there's no
criteria you need to hit or certain
amount of followers or certain amount of
you know engagement that you need to
unlock this feature everyone is supposed
to have 60 second reels yet some people
can only go up to 30 seconds some people
can even only go up to 15. and i've even
heard there's plenty of people who still
don't even have access to reels even
though they are supposed to um it's not
that instagram hates you it's not that
um you know mark zuckerberg or adam
mozari is out to get you um it's just an
unfortunate glitch in the system that
unfortunately you know not quite all
users have access to all of the same
features just yet but technically
everyone is supposed to have access to
reels and the full 60 second recording
option
amazing and so you know uh some people
are saying they haven't done any uh
reels yet they've done you know
carousels um
men pursuing excellence is doing reels
and explore with andy is doing real so
brock you're saying if we're spending
time on instagram we need to be doing
reels period yeah absolutely if you only
have time to make one post per day on
instagram one feed post that is i would
prioritize making a real i would
prioritize making a real um just because
right now they have that uh golden
ticket type of of virality component
they can reach
massive amounts of people i like to say
that they're like lottery tickets and so
sean how do you increase your odds of
winning the lottery you got three
options you either pray really really
hard you catch a leprechaun or the most
reliable way to win the lotteries you
buy a lot of lottery tickets and so
let's translate that into social media
and instagram speak the way you increase
your odds of winning the lottery on
instagram having a post go viral is you
post more reels
amazing uh i'm pumped to also catch a
leprechaun though that's my dream uh and
get me lucky charms but hey what's tip
number two yeah so tip number two and
this one i hope um is a breath of fresh
air and a sigh of relief for everyone
and that's that hashtags should no
longer be your focus and i might be so
bold as to say that hashtags don't
really even matter too much
there's been a lot of talk over the last
year or two about different things that
instagram is introducing to replace
hashtags they're really beefing up their
searching capabilities they're really
beefing up
their artificial intelligence they're
beefing up it's their own ability to
search for keywords and to categorize
your posts without relying on you to do
so with hashtags and that was really uh
the point that hashtags existed for was
to be a way for you to categorize your
posts kind of like adding a keyword or a
tag
to your youtube videos but hashtags are
no longer really that important we're
starting to see that they're very very
very inconsistent at best even the the
top list even if you hired a team of 15
experts to get you this perfect list of
hashtags
our studies are showing that
they're just still not very consistent
even this finely tuned perfect list
is just not very consistent and not very
reliable
and so my point that i've been making
recently my argument that i've been
making is that we should all just stop
stressing out so much about hashtags i
don't think there's something that we
should
be spending hours every single day
researching and what's my best list and
oh did this one work or did this one
work and there's also a million
different best practices i've heard
people say you should use 30. i've heard
instagram themselves literally instagram
staff say you should use 8 to 15 and
then i heard instagram again last week
they changed it up and they said no you
should probably only use three to five
and yet they allow you to use 30 so why
wouldn't they allow us to use all 30. so
it's very confusing
it's very unreliable and for that reason
i say that we just shouldn't stress
about them there's a lot better focuses
and ways that we can spend our time um
and i will say this and people might not
like to hear this if you're not growing
on instagram it's not because of your
hashtags
that's a money tip right there and
that's one of those new updates that is
important to pay attention to because
you don't want to be spinning your way
wheels and wasting your time on the
things that are not making an impact in
the things that
don't matter well you have three more
updates that we're going to get into we
also have some questions coming and we
want to answer your questions about
instagram but um today's episode is
actually brought to by us by a free boot
camp you're doing
brought to coffee with kennel buy the
free three day grow your gram uh boot
camp i can't wait because the think
media team and i are going to
participate in this because we need to
level up our instagram
um if you want to get a free ticket it's
uh it's at
bestigtips.com of course there's a link
in the description down below brock
what's happening with this uh boot camp
yeah i'm super fired up for this
bootcamp so this bootcamp is my mom and
i i think that's the first thing i want
to say is that it's my mom and i and so
for people who don't know my mom um
she's not just like some random old lady
who happens to be joining me to hang out
uh for this boot camp uh i like to say
like my mom's like an og when it comes
to the digital marketing space she's got
over 700 000 followers on instagram
she's made millions of dollars in sales
on instagram growing five different
businesses and different niches and
genres and so we're teaming up to bring
you this free boot camp and that's the
first thing i want to
make sure it's very clear about the boot
camp it's totally free and like sean
said it's best ig tips.com but in the
boot camp we're going to be teaching you
not just how to grow your following not
just how to increase your engagement and
get some more views because that stuff
is cool but at the end of the day we're
all business owners we want to know how
can i
leverage this platform to grow my email
list to grow my subscriber list to grow
my customer list how can i actually make
sales on instagram and that's really
what we're going to be focusing on
during the three-day grow your grand
boot camp is we're going to actually
teach you
the insider secrets of how we've been
able to sell and convert with our
accounts with all of our clients
accounts in just about every industry
every niche we're going to give
templates sean we're going to give
breakdowns of exactly what to say where
selling happens the trust formula um and
all that good stuff so i really want to
encourage anyone um even if you don't
have a thousand followers yet or you
don't have a landing page or you don't
necessarily even have a business or a
product to sell yet head to
bestigtips.com
and grab your free ticket
amazing and so uh we of course link that
up in the description down below and
we've collabed with uh brock and shaleen
in the past and so we definitely wanted
to get that on your radar but so far
you've said number one
reels we got to be using reels reels are
getting free game reels are getting the
reach
and even living with a longer shelf life
don't pay too much attention to hashtags
that's a major change everyone freaks
out about those little tactics and
thinks that there's a magical hashtag
kind of like a magical youtube tag
that's gonna like unlock you know the
leprechauns but that's just not how it
works um and so with that uh what's your
next tip and update that we need to know
and pay attention to
yeah so this one came out a few months
ago and this was from adam mozari who is
the head of instagram he's the ceo of
instagram and he posted a video on his
channel basically saying that we are no
longer a photo sharing app and everyone
lost their mind it'd be like if if
youtube's ceo said we are no longer a
video sharing app and so everyone lost
their mind and they started saying
we can't grow if we're not using video
posts and photos are dead they'll never
work anymore this app has totally
changed what is going on
and what i think we really all needed to
realize from what he said is that
really instagram is no longer just
a photo sharing app and since 2012 when
instagram added video to the platform
for the first time it's been no longer
just a photo sharing app so i want to
first of all calm everyone's nurbs
nerves and say that if you don't like
video and i know that we're a youtube
audience here and we love video but if
you don't post videos and reels on
instagram it's okay you can still grow
but if you are doing video
video is king on instagram it absolutely
is i know we talked about reels earlier
but even just yesterday instagram made
another big announcement and that's that
they're pretty much going to be
dissolving igtv and so for people who
don't know what ig tv is it is
the uh long-form video component of
instagram it's basically instagram's way
to compete with youtube oftentimes
people take their youtube videos and
just post them as ig tvs
so instagram isn't removing the ability
to post long form videos what they're
actually doing sean is they're combining
igtvs which are any video on instagram
longer than a minute
with just normal instagram videos which
are any videos on instagram shorter than
a minute and they're just making it one
big umbrella category called instagram
video
and so it might look on the surface like
instagram is turning away from video or
they're moving away from ig tv but
really
this shows us that they're trying to
make
long-form video and video in general
more accessible um and more broadly
consumed on the instagram platform
sheesh
wow
wow
that's like some hot news right off the
presses and uh i think we
um that's super interesting because of
course we repurpose a lot of our youtube
content and we we put it into two three
four five six minute clips um but super
interesting uh with that being said
video is king and so we gotta stay on
our toes that's the power of this boot
camp too man
so much i need to know brock but uh let
me know if um
do you use igtv are you using reels how
much are you posting on instagram and uh
what is maybe the most effective uh
content format that you've been posting
on instagram uh coffee with kennel crew
all right uh hit us with the next one
brock yep the next one is that all forms
of engagement matter on instagram and i
would even go so far as to say that all
forms of engagement on instagram are
pretty much equal there was this um
this blog that came out in 2017
stating that
saves are the new like there's no such
like likes don't matter anymore you know
when someone double taps a photo those
don't matter anymore and now saves are
all that matter and
the article went so far as to claim that
saves are like super likes and that
saves um are the magic trick they get
you out of the shadow band and they're
the most important form of engagement
for blowing up your instagram
fast forward about two or three years
and a couple media agencies found this
old blog post and they turned it into an
instagram infographic like a text post
on instagram and it said it put them in
order it put the forms of engagement in
order and it said that saves are a super
like they're the most important form of
engagement and then shares were number
two and then comments and then likes
were the least important and you
shouldn't really worry about likes
and this post went viral
but i love the reason it went viral it
went viral because people were sharing
it a ton people were liking it they were
commenting on it they were engaging with
it in every way besides just saving it
and so the point that i want to make is
that all forms of engagement matter
saves are not a super like likes matter
comments matter of any length
saves shares all of those things matter
and actually there's plenty of forms of
engagement that we don't think about
necessarily because we don't see them
tracked in our stats that matter as well
such as views are people coming back to
your videos are people going from your
post that you just made to your profile
and spending some time there or are they
just continuing to scroll with the rest
of the apps there's a lot more
engagement than meets the eye so to
speak but that's a tip that i want to
give for everyone is that all forms of
engagement matter and so you shouldn't
just prioritize or only focus on one
some posts you should encourage
commenting sometimes you should give a
call to action relating to sharing or
just related to liking your post all
forms of engagement matter and we
shouldn't forget about everything else
besides saves
man that's a big insight and if you
haven't actually connected with brock on
instagram you can see his handle on the
screen brock 11 johnson i've learned so
much from brock so what i'm hearing is
that if someone likes my post that's
good if someone leaves a comment that's
great if someone shares it that's also
potentially great because that also
could lead them sharing it to reach new
people
besides just the algorithmic reach if
someone saves it that's good but also
if someone dwells on it and that's it's
kind of like think about how youtube
works watch time average view duration
they want time on platform
and they're they're if you skip off one
video but you spend time on somebody
else's video the youtube algorithms like
oh
we like that you're spending time on
this person's video we should show it to
more people because that kind of video
keeps people on platform
thus
potentially a carousel that someone
swipes across they're staying on that
post longer potentially
a caption that someone spends time
reading or even if they click read more
that would be an action right bro
absolutely absolutely yeah no that
that's a great one sean um and that
brings me to another point which is that
everyone believes you need to write a
long caption or your video if it can be
up to 60 seconds it needs to be the full
60 seconds that's great
as long as you're holding people's
attention so like sean said if you can
write an engaging caption below your
instagram post and get people to tap on
that read more and get them to spend
some time dwelling on your post well
that's going to be great for the
instagram algorithm because instagram is
noticing that people are spending time
with your content but if you can't get
people to read that caption if you can't
get them to swipe through your full post
or to watch your full video and instead
at the four second mark they're bored
they're over it and they're going to
continue scrolling and they or they
might leave the app all together
that's
disadvantageous for your instagram
account and that's going to hurt you
in the algorithm and then one other
thing that you mentioned sean that i
wanted to bring up again is that yes
shares if i had to pick my favorite or
my most preferred form of engagement
it's a share and that's because of
course when someone shares my content at
least one other person is guaranteed to
see it so it's a way to
reach new people without relying on the
algorithm
man super powerful if you've been
getting value out of this video can we
get it to 50 likes coffee with candle
crew smash that like button and maybe
share this video with somebody who needs
this instagram information don actually
says this is extremely valuable
information i gotta get back to work
though will this be posted on youtube
later yes you can catch the replay here
and if you haven't subscribed to the
think media podcast channel this is
where we do the coffee with kennel show
and uh we have guests like brock
bringing you the latest and most
important information
um that you need to know tim from wales
says my instagram reels are getting 10
times the views over youtube shorts and
tick tock at the moment brock i just got
back from vid summit with some of the
think media team and word on the street
from multiple creators was they were
like dude reels are going crazy man
reels are like getting organic reach
that i haven't seen in a long time on
any platform would you agree with that
yeah absolutely i was fortunate enough
kind of lucked into it i did catch a
leprechaun with being on tick tock in
early 2019. so i think tick tock really
blew up in 2020 during quarantine
everyone's at home watching tick tock
and it kind of blew up but i think i was
really fortunate to get on tick tock
super early i think that was one of the
first times i was on a platform in the
early days and so i got to experience
what that rapid growth was like every
single one of my videos was going viral
and reaching thousands and thousands of
people
and what i've started to see is that for
the last year
instagram has been that way with reels
and it hasn't changed and even right now
the train hasn't left the station you
can still hop on the wheels the the
reels bandwagon and start to see massive
growth organic reach and success
with instagram reels
wow the train hasn't left the station
number one you gotta be using reels
number two hashtags don't carry the
weight they used to might be a waste of
your time number three video is king
major igtv update number four all
engagement is good get that engagement
but shares power tip is maybe one of the
best ways to reach new people because
they're sharing it with their community
did you sneak in tip number five or do
we have another tip here brock
i have another one for you i have
another one and this one might be the
most important one that i want people to
hear and understand
all right well uh drop it on us and then
we will answer some questions so drop a
question in the
absolutely so number five
the more you post the more you grow
and i was looking back through my own
instagram and even about two years ago i
was anti this tip i was saying don't
post too much or you will overwhelm your
audience don't post too much or your
posts will compete against each other
don't post too often or people will
unfollow you
and i no longer believe that's the case
and now with over a billion people on
instagram i think that it's necessary to
post more in order to grow so i think if
you want a goal to set for yourself i
think your goal should be at least
one post a day everyone wants to know
the minimum that's your minimum one post
per day if you want to grow on instagram
if you want serious growth if you want
maximum growth it's two or three or four
or even five
feed posts per day i'm not talking about
stories right now i'm just talking about
the feed posts so the reels the
carousels uh the the the videos and the
plain image text posts that you make on
your instagram profile
multiple per day in order to grow and
the reason for that is that there's way
more people on instagram now so there's
way more competition there's way more
fish in the sea and so in order to make
sure that your posts are seen at all
and you're not out of sight out of mind
you need to be posting more
man uh
super powerful and we understand the
power of consistency
and even quantity on youtube if we can
keep the quality of those posts
high as well um
drop in the comments if you can discover
the secret graffiti word uh that is um
in brock's
studio set i don't think he wrote it but
let me know if you can read it as the uh
where's waldo of the day
um today's episode is brought to you by
free the three the free three day
grow your grand boot camp if you're
loving this instagram information
obviously there's so many tips brock
could get into about about earning money
about sales about engagement about dms
about uh how do you do it all about
systems about batching about stories
about all this kind of stuff best
igtips.com make sure to register it's
coming up uh starts october 12th through
the 14th it is live it is free so you're
going to want to register so you can
actually be there and attend
um and check out youtube
check out the description
check out the link in the description
down below extra points for those
guessing the uh graffiti word scare
uh brock you you should go down there
and tag that bridge
with like your instagram handle right
absolutely
that would be great if i was like
there's my instagram handle and i just
pointed to the graffiti on the freeway
out of my seattle window or if like you
were doing like a challenge or something
and uh a training a boot camp and
someone was out there like making a
mural and then you're like and then it
was like you're like and that is why
reels are so important and they like
reveal it and it's like reals is written
on the bridge they're all like pretty uh
absolutely that's funny so um
so definitely jump into the boot camp
hey if you have a question drop a
question we're going to take a couple
questions and i'm going to have a quick
bio review crash course
on my bio from brock but andy asks
should ig content be unique or can you
get away with posting youtube clips
i think you can get away with it i think
you can get away with it but sean
there's something that i've heard you
say before which is that every platform
has its own dress code and the dress
code on youtube is longer form videos
often times horizontal or landscape
style videos and on instagram that just
doesn't work as well and it's just a
difference of where we're consuming
we're watching youtube oftentimes either
on our phone turns sideways or on a on a
laptop screen a computer screen or on
the tv
on instagram we don't watch it sideways
we watch it vertical so the videos
should be vertical
but as long as they're shot in the right
format and as long as they look like
they were made for
instagram or for reals i think it's okay
to post your youtube videos onto
instagram i just think make sure it's
fitting
what people expect on instagram and as
of right now people don't expect long
form videos they're not watching videos
much longer than three or four minutes
on instagram most people are preferring
videos that are less than a minute on
instagram so just make sure you are
dressing up your video content
appropriately to fit the platform
that's amazing uh if you haven't
followed brock you can also study his
kind of real strategy over here here's
some of his reels from 11k recently
posted to 297 000 views and uh
brock definitely is dropping massive
instagram value so so check him out over
here but brock i just noticed something
and i'm like wait a minute i don't have
guides what is this guides tab
yeah uh guides is something that you
have it once you post it so once you
post a guide then you'll have this
little guide section um and guides are
something that instagram came out with
about a year ago now
and they never really caught on much
popularity and that's just because they
don't have a reach when you put together
a guide it doesn't get shown to people
it doesn't show up anywhere it doesn't
it's not searchable
um so it's just kind of something that
exists on your channel you can kind of
think of it like a playlist on youtube
imagine if you could you know take a
playlist and put it on your channel
except for that's not really popular and
they can't be you know found i can't
just be scrolling through instagram and
find someone's guide it can really only
be found if i'm looking at your profile
but what is cool about guides is you can
take your own posts and you can take
even posts from other people's accounts
and you can put them all together into
one playlist and you know title it
something that's all related to one
topic like i think you were just going
through one of mine about
engagement tips or something like that
they just haven't caught on much
popularity and they don't really help
you grow your following so it's not
really something that i recommend people
spend much time thinking about or
looking into
great tip a great question came in about
monetization but i want to
transition into your money tips about
what what what could i do to maybe level
up my bio or what are some things i
should be thinking about that the coffee
with cannell community
could also maybe do an overhaul in their
bio their profile uh that you maybe see
here on
channel on uh instagram absolutely so if
you're if you're watching right now make
sure you listen up because this is
something that um a lot of the small
tweaks that i'm about to give sean are
things that you could make on your
account as well the first two boxes that
i want to check off and give you an a
plus grade on are first of all your
username it's your first and last name
way to go checked off that box and
second your profile picture it's a high
quality well-lit close-up selfie the
background has been removed so it's just
a solid color so it really pops off the
page love what you've done with the
username and the profile picture
next and this is a change i would
recommend you make do you see where it
says sean cannell uh the second time yep
right there that is what's known as your
instagram name and that is arguably the
most searchable area on your instagram
profile
so because it says sean cannell again
the only way that someone can really
right now
search and find your profile is if
they're searching sean cannell
so what i would recommend you do and
what i would recommend everyone watching
do is on that line give yourself a title
give yourself something that people
would be searching give yourself some
sort of of of like recognizable
title yeah youtube strategy youtube
strategist i think on mine it says um ig
expert top podcaster
youtube coach things like that whatever
it is that you do whatever your niche or
your industry is
that's what should go in that name line
because it's highly searchable and we
don't need to have your name because we
already have your name up in the
username
and you don't even need the name or
should i do both
you can do both it doesn't hurt to do
both i know there's only a certain
amount of characters that you can put
there um so you can do both but we don't
necessarily even need your name because
it's already in your username
real-time updates here coffee with
candle crew we got the money tips
and then how's the bio look and what
should i be doing with these highlights
yeah so highlights very similar to
guides they're something that not a ton
of people watch i like to keep my first
two or three highlights updated and my
first two or three highlights are like
an about me which i see you have
i like to have a highlight maybe
relating to whatever my current offer is
or
whatever it is i'm trying to promote or
whatever i get asked about all the time
so if i'm always getting asked uh hey do
you have a link to this video or hey can
you tell me more about this thing i'll
create a highlight around that just so i
can easily direct people to it
but besides that you know highlights
they're just not that commonly watched
they don't really make that huge of a
difference in terms of people following
you um but the one highlight that we
have seen that people really do like to
watch and engage with is an about me
which i know we're watching yours right
now it can be a great way to just kind
of introduce your followers to who you
are and give them like a like a crash
course into hey you're following me now
get up to speed here's your baseline
and so in about me i've seen people call
it start here that's a great way to get
people to actually click on it
but ultimately overall i wouldn't put
too much of a stress or importance on
highlights in general
amazing and then uh my bio brock do you
think it's all right
yeah let me get back there yeah let's
pull that up um overall i like the way
your bio looks i think it reads pretty
much abc the way we want it to um the a
is who do i serve or what's my niche and
so your says i help people build their
influence with youtube
i would challenge you sean to get more
specific than just people
who are those people who are the video
influencers that's what i would
challenge you and that's what i would
challenge everyone to answer in the
first sentence of their bio
who specifically do i help or do i serve
and then the second part is how do i
serve them or what do i help them with
so sean helps people with in uh with
their influence build their influence
with youtube so that's his what that's
what he does and that's um what i'm
challenging him is to get even more
specific with who that group of people
is
the second part of your bio i think you
did it excellently is kind of just like
establishing your credibility so forbes
top 20 youtube channel for business
check awesome perfect that's some
serious credibility that establishes why
we should trust you and follow you and
then you have a call to action which i
think is awesome that's the c in the abc
formula you have a call to action at the
end of your bio yours says watch my
brand new video on youtube here i like
it because it's gonna drive some traffic
to your youtube and if that's the the
purpose of your um
your instagram channel your instagram
profile is to drive people to your
youtube that's totally fine the one
thing that i will say is that might be
driving people to your youtube and not
driving them to actually press the
follow button and stay engaged on
instagram
so you know there's pros and cons to
that and at different times i change my
call to action sometimes it's telling
people to go to a link sometimes it's
telling people just to follow me so you
can change up that that call to action
at the end of your bio pretty regularly
depending on what you want people to do
at the moment when they come to your
profile
sheesh that's some good killer tips and
i definitely you know even my
understanding of youtube is the best way
to grow on youtube is youtube itself
it's it's hard to send traffic from
somewhere else and i would think the
same would be true on instagram that
like i think i would much prefer to keep
engagement happening there education
happening there those follows happening
there man i got a lot of work to do and
that's why i'm fired up uh
for the boot camp i have one last
question about monetization but if
you're just joining and you haven't
heard brock is doing a free
three-day grow your grand boot camp with
chalene johnson um and brock johnson
um founders of insta club hub and so
anyways that's happening october 12th
definitely get registered the ticket is
free and they're going to be breaking
down all of this and more in an
intensive that you can um use so that
you cannot just get more followers and
reach on instagram but also
make
money and check that out but a good
question kind of came in because i know
you know the insider scoop tell me about
how monetization works
on instagram and a question somebody was
asking specifically
about that i will say this we just
received this last month our first check
from facebook inc
direct deposit uh for views on instagram
content we made 128
dollars
um and so that definitely beats a poke
in the eye in a kick in the pants
uh but uh what is happening with
instagram monetization of your videos
yeah some really cool things are going
on over there first of all you're now
able to add an ad or turn on ads i
should say for your longer videos what
was formerly known as igtv and what is
now just going to be known as instagram
video you can monetize those and turn on
ads um i recommend doing it on all of
your videos you might as well um and
i've like you said sean started to
receive checks in the mail from
facebook inc from uh getting plays on my
videos and so far my instagram videos my
ig tvs haven't gone viral they haven't
reached millions of followers or
millions of people yet
but turning on those ads has started to
monetize them and start to get some
adsense money uh come in from those
videos additionally um instagram is
starting to turn on ads for reals that's
going to be really powerful of course
because like we've been talking about
reels have such a high reach and they
get viewed by so many people so your
likelihood of earning some monetized
dollars from your reels
is going to be really powerful really
cool um and then also
instagram is offering bonuses now for
real so over the summer they gave
bonuses for going live if you went live
on instagram instagram was literally
just paying you for going live even if
no one was watching even if you only
went live for like 15 minutes instagram
was just paying people bonuses of a
couple hundred bucks uh per live video
which was really cool and now they're
bringing that same idea or that same
incentive to reels so starting in 2022
they're gonna start paying people
depending on the uh performance of your
reels you get a couple thousand views
they're gonna pay you a couple hundred
bucks which is gonna be really really
cool um and of course they're they're
beefing up the instagram shop and
they're allowing people to run ads on
reels so
i think they're really trying to help
out the creators and uh pump more
thought and more tools out relating to
monetization
wow so many money tips in this episode
and uh people are grabbing their tickets
for the boot camp and so
um i want to honor brock's time today
uh let's see if we can get this video to
a hundred likes if you got value today
you could definitely connect with brock
on instagram to learn more but do not
miss the free boot camp and that's
coming up you have some time to get
registered make some plans uh get your
journal ready get your notes ready what
you'll discover is just as much value as
brock added in this video uh him and
chalene johnson who you may or just be
meeting them but we've been
collaborating uh over the last five plus
years seven years maybe uh besides
instagram and youtube stuff uh we both
are avid and passionate snowboarders
we've uh been in park city snowboarding
together so brock is actually
uh is absolutely a world-class human and
a world-class business and social media
expert that i can't recommend enough so
don't miss the bootcamp the url is
bestigtips.com there's also a link in
the description down below so you can
get registered brock the future of
instagram um you know i'm convinced here
but for those that also say man there's
so much to do there's so many places to
invest my time and what if
is this thing on the decline you know
like if i get started now am i late to
the party or like what's the future
projections you know we've been seeing
that youtube is adding more users and
more functionality much like instagram
so just kind of what's your nutshell
vision of where instagram is going and
the opportunity there
yeah so really when i when i think about
social media and the future of it i
think that there's kind of like a big
three that i'm noticing right now um i
think youtube is one i think youtube is
always going to be here to stay i think
long form video content youtube has
established a presence it's
searchability all of the different
features and tools that it's constantly
adding and upgrading i think youtube is
absolutely awesome
i think that tick-tock is also here to
stay i think that tick-tock came onto
the scene with a burst a year ago
and people are just really loving it i
think that there's a powerful algorithm
there but what i think tick-tock is
lacking compared to youtube is i think
where instagram fits in onto the scene
as the kind of third of this
three-headed monster where it is
designed for mobile yet it has so many
tools and so many different functions it
has
so many different kinds of content to
really make all people happy whether you
do long form video you do short form
video you do pictures photography text
posts you're all about stories and
vlogging and documenting lifestyle sort
of stuff if you love live videos if you
love just connecting with people in
message threads i think that instagram
really has all of that to offer and from
what we've seen in terms of the actual
data and the actual numbers
instagram is really adding a lot more
users they're now over a billion users
on instagram they're continuing to add
more specifically for creators and for
entrepreneurs and for business owners
so i really do think that instagram is
definitely here to stay they're adding
users and they're growing in popularity
as well while
seems like it's kind of a mixed bag of
reviews around facebook these days seems
like a lot of facebook users are
migrating to spend most of their time on
instagram and i think that's only going
to of course uh be beneficial for all of
us using instagram in the future
wow and you know the interesting thing
too about what you were just talking
about about these big three is that you
have reels you have of course tick tock
and then you have youtube shorts and we
know a lot of creators and people we
partner with and collaborate with that
are creating content in such a way that
they're they're creating it without the
music so they can use the trending music
on each platform you know integrated
organically from that platform and
they're crushing it with youtube shorts
tick tocks and instagram and repurposing
and cross-promoting or rather uploading
them natively to each platform and
getting a lot of leverage and reach out
of those so i would completely agree
um when it comes to social media
platforms to be focusing on and that
also would be a good you know time
saving tip how am i going to have time
to do it all we have we actually have a
tick tock now it's called the official
think media and so we have seen some uh
great impact from
uh some of our youtube shorts that then
we'll post on tick tock later maybe
remix it a little bit post it on reels
later and so we're getting so much more
leverage and saving time because that's
one of the huge keys in this thing
absolutely you can kill three birds with
one stone because a real can become a
tick tock can become an i or youtube
short all three at once and they can be
pretty much the exact same video with
just a few minor tweaks
yes man brock johnson really grateful
for all the value you uh dropped today
uh so many questions are coming in if
you want to connect with brock moore and
learn more about instagram hit up the
bootcamp best
igtips.com it's starting in just a few
days um and smash the like button if you
got value out of this session today now
listen brock was actually on the think
media podcast recently so if you are
looking for something else to watch and
you want to go deeper with strategy for
him
from him just click or tap the screen to
watch that video and i cannot wait to
see you in the next episode of coffee
with kannel take care